MALE SPEAKER: I want to actually
send out a congratulations
to a couple applications that
were just launched on Google
Play while that
talk was going on.
So if any of you pushed
the Publish button on this,
give yourself a
round of applause.
Flappy Toaster.
Nobody?
No one?
That wasn't?
We also got Floppy Dog,
Flippy Shoe, Clumsy Brick,
and Flappy Fowl.
No?
That wasn't anybody in here?
OK.
All right.
Well, for those of you who
aren't making Flappy Bird
clones, or perhaps
just are, here
to talk about
multiplayer services
is Doctor Todd Kerpelman.
Give him a round of applause.
TODD KERPELMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE] Not an actual doctor.
Let's swap this out, make
sure this is working.
Hey, look at that.
Alright, we've got
our presentation.
So thank you very
much for hanging out.
Today we have a lot
of presentations
and not a lot of
time to do them all.
So-- oh, and I should
reset the timer.
Look at that.
Awesome.
So I'm just to going to get
right into the presentation
and tell you a little story
about the Kerpelman household.
So right now, I am
an iOS developer,
or at least I do
some iOS development.
So I have an iPhone.
And my wife has a
very lovely Moto X.
And right now, there's a lot
that we can do with each other,
with these phones.
Right?
Like I can send her a
text message and say,
hey, I'm going to be
home late tonight.
There's a lot of
meetings at 10 o'clock.
And my wife can send
me back an email.
And I could send
her a Snap Chat.
Wait for it.
There we go.
Because I'm totally into
Chinese trading vessels.
And we can send each
other various messages
through different kind
of messaging services
like WhatsApp.
We can even do
this thing where we
can communicate through
real time voice.
I forget what it's called.
Oh, right.
Making phone calls.
We can do that too, right?
But suppose we actually wanted
to play together, play a game.
Oh, sorry.
You can't do that.
I mean, I guess
we could ask you,
the small indie developer, to go
ahead and spend a lot of money
on some back end
services and then
go ahead and add in all that
network code to your client
and deal with all
the infrastructure,
and then spend a whole bunch
of time working on UI work
where you can
invite your friends
and make sure they're
listed in the people picker.
And then add in all
that code scaffolding
so that your cross platform game
can then talk to the libraries
that you've written on the
Android and the iOS side.
And then I suppose
in the time that you
have remaining before
you ship, maybe
you could work on your game.
And really?
Is that the best we can do?
How do we get to a point
where we think this is OK?
If our phones couldn't
call each other,
we would be taking
them back to the stores
and saying this thing is
broken, I want my money back.
Why should games
be any different?
And I don't think
they should be.
And so that brings us to
Google Play Games services.
And what you may or may
not know about Play Games
services is that one
of our core tenets
is that the entire experience
should be cross platform.
I think a lot of
developers out there
still think we are Android only.
And maybe that's
because we're Google,
or maybe it's just
the green in the logo.
I think we should have gone
for a nice multicolored logo.
But the fact of the
matter is, we've
had library support both
for Android and from iOS
when we first launched.
Yeah, sorry.
I wasn't quite sure
legally-- anyway.
And so we do love both
of these platforms.
And we should point
out we also have a REST
service available for everything
so that any device that
can access the internet could
access these games services.
Right?
And if in the future one
day your refrigerator's
hooked up to the internet, you
could unlock an achievement
for eating the last
of the ice cream.
And so we've had library
support for a lot
of these cross
platform features.
Right?
We've had cross platform
achievements and Cloud Save,
which can be really
cool if you happen
to use both types of
devices regularly.
I do.
You know, I can play
a game on my iPhone
and save it to the
cloud, and then
continue from where I
left off on a Nexus 7.
And that's pretty cool.
When you see that happen,
it's kind of magic.
And I'm guessing for a lot
of people in this room,
you also have multiple
brands of devices
that you're using
at the same time.
Granted, probably among
the general population,
this isn't quite so comment.
But things do get
more interesting
once we bring in cross
platform leader boards.
Then even if I am a one brand
device kind of household,
I can still compare my scores
with that of my friends.
Again, no matter what
kind of device they're on.
And then we've had
multiplayer support.
And it's been a
little incomplete.
So we launched with support
for real time multiplayer
on Android devices back
when the service first
launched about 10 months ago.
And then we added
support for turn
based asynchronous
multiplayer games.
Again, on Android devices,
about two months ago.
But something has been missing.
And so what we are super excited
to be launching this week
is cross platform multiplayer
for both Android and iOS
devices.
Hooray.
[APPLAUSE] Yeah!
You can clap for that.
That's cool.
And so you might be
asking, well, OK,
this is great, but is
it really worth it?
This suddenly seems
like extra headaches.
I now have to keep these
two clients in sync
when I push out an update.
And my answer is yes.
I guess it would be, otherwise
I wouldn't be giving this talk.
For multiple reasons.
The first, honestly, it
is a really cool trick.
The first time you see a
cross platform real time
game across an iPad and a
Nexus 7, it's kind of magic.
You're like, how
did that happen?
What kind of crazy
sorcery is this?
Right?
So it is very cool, and you'll
get street cred, I guess,
if you can make this happen.
The second thing,
honestly, is I think
it's the right thing to do.
As game developers,
we've been saying forever
that games are the
ultimate social experience.
That our ancestors,
once they were
able to hunt enough
meat to not starve
and they were able to get loin
cloths and hang out in caves,
the next thing they did was
they played games together.
Right?
Games are sort of the
ultimate social experience.
People have been
doing it forever.
Animals do it.
It's a fantastic thing.
And it seems kind
of weird and broken
that not everybody can play
games with all their friends
because they just chose to buy
a different brand of phone.
So I think we need to fix this.
And then honestly just from
a technical point of view,
you're going to have
much better matchmaking.
And I'll drill into
this a little bit.
If you think about a
typical mobile multiplayer
setup, generally
speaking, you're
going to have a client
peer to peer mesh network.
Something sort of like this,
where all these devices are
talking directly to each other.
And what we find in
these kinds of situations
is the quality of
your game experience
is directly proportional
to the number of people
you have playing
at any given time.
So if there's a lot
of people playing,
you're going to have a really
good multiplayer experience.
You know, by contrast, if you
had a really sparse network,
if you didn't have a
lot of people looking
to play at any
point, you're going
to have fewer options when
it comes to matchmaking.
You might find that your
players in San Francisco,
their only option is going
to be some player way
the heck on the other side
of the world in South Africa.
And no matter how
hard you try, you're
not going to get a great
connection time there.
You can't increase
the speed of light.
You also might
find that it takes
a lot longer for
your players to find
somebody else to play with.
Right?
Again, you've got
a sparse network.
Maybe not a lot of
people are looking
to play at any given
moment of the day.
Your players have to wait
longer to find matches.
And they'll get bored and leave.
I think we've found that
your players will start
to leave in significant numbers
after like 12 seconds, which
isn't really a lot of time.
And so what if we were able
to take your pool of players
and double it?
So at this point now, we
have a much richer pool
of potential
opponents that we can
start matching up
against each other.
And that means one,
we can match up
people who we know are going
to have better internet
connections, who are close
to each other geographically.
And two, we can match
them up much faster.
So you have a much better
matchmaking experience
happening much, much quicker.
And so I think
that's pretty good.
So this is a lot of talk.
Let's show a brief demo.
This is Battle Pillars.
This is an upcoming
version of Battle Pillars
from the developers Hit Sense.
They were kind enough
to start hacking
with this library for us.
And they already had
their Android version
of their game working
using Play Games services.
And then all in all, it probably
took them less than a week
to get the iOS version
working and talking
to the Android versions as well.
They probably could have
done it a lot faster
if we weren't swapping out the
library on them every week.
But that's what happens when
you're in early development.
So let's talk a little more
about the real time multiplayer
aspects.
So we do set up a
peer to peer network
between different devices.
A player can, of course,
choose to invite their friends.
But if they do decide
they want to auto match,
we're fairly intelligent about
who we auto match players up
against.
So we've got probably 10 months
worth of machine learning
data built up
where we've started
to learn that not
only do players
in the same general
geographic location
tend to have better
connections, but also we've
learned that, oh, players in
city A and players in city
B for some reason-- maybe
the tube on the interwebs
is really big between
those two cities--
have really good
connection speeds.
But players in city A
and players in city C
don't connect very well.
And so we've started to
learn about what players
will potentially play
well together simply
based on sort of
connection time.
And we've learned that generally
over the last few months.
So once we are able to
intelligently match up people,
we can get them
together in a game.
The devices will then connect
up to each other directly
through a peer to
peer mesh network that
looks a little
something like this.
We do allow you to
choose variants and bit
masks so that if, for
instance, your game had
a capture the flag and a
team death match variant,
and you found that your
players only wanted to match up
with other people that were
playing team death match,
we could get rid of those
players that were-- sorry--
get rid of those players that
were looking to play capture
the flag and make sure that
you only get matched up
with other people looking to
play the same type of game
as you.
We do a fair amount of
work around NAT busting.
I don't understand all the
technical details myself,
but generally
speaking, if you find
that your user is
behind a firewall
or is unable to connect
with another device,
we generally figure
out a way around this.
I think in roughly
92% of the time.
As for those other
8% of your players,
if they are behind some
incredibly strict firewall that
simply doesn't allow
them to connect
to another device
no matter what,
we will allow them
to send their game
messages through Google servers.
So they can send
their messages to us,
and then we can relay
that on to the player
they were trying to connect to.
And obviously,
this is much slower
than connecting to
another device directly,
but we are going on the
theory that any connection is
better than no
connection at all.
We also do support invitations,
as I mentioned earlier.
Suppose you want to invite
specific people to play a game.
Those work as well.
I think, as you saw
in the last slide,
we do send messages to Android
devices using Google Cloud
Messaging.
But we also send Apple
push notifications
to users with iOS devices.
You would upload your
push notification certs
to our server, and then we
would use those to make calls
to players on behalf
of your application.
And so what that means is
whether your application is
running, whether it's
running in the background,
whether it's been
terminated for memory,
your user will still
get that notification.
They can click on it.
It will bring up your
game with the data
available in that
notification payload.
And you're then able to
jump right into a game
no matter what state
that your game was
in before, which
is kind of nice.
Messages can be sent two ways.
There's reliable, this
is when we absolutely
want to make sure a message
is received by another player.
This means that messages are
guaranteed to be received.
You will receive a receipt
that the message was read.
All these reliable
messages are guaranteed
to be received in the
order they were sent.
But of course, this tends
to be a little slower.
And then we have
unreliable messages.
This is where you
say, I don't care
about dropping messages or
messages being received out
of order.
Just send this
data as fast as you
can to all the other players.
For those of you who know
about network protocols,
this first one is
basically XMPP,
and this bottom one is UDP.
Or I guess I should
say it's usually UDP.
Sometimes it's not.
And so generally the way
we see game developers use
this is they will send
a reliable message
for initial game set up,
and hey the game is over,
here are the final results.
And then they'll use
unreliable messages
for most of the other
game messaging in between.
And in case I didn't make
it clear at the beginning,
all of this is totally free.
So goodbye, bag of money.
I don't know why you're
storing your money
in a big sack like that anyway.
Our whole point here is we
want to make gaming better.
And that means one,
making multiplayer games
truly multiplayer.
But that also means
making sure that you
can spend more time on
gameplay and less time
on boring stuff
like network code
and dealing with backend
infrastructure issues.
So we've talked a little about
the real time multiplayer.
Let me give you a few
details about the turn-based
asynchronous
multiplayer aspects.
Like in real time
multiplayer, we
allow you to match up with
people through invitations.
Or we can automatch you
with other random folks
out there on the internet.
Again, we also, by the way,
allow you to mix and match.
If you want to start
a five player game
and want to invite
two specific people
and just want to be automatched
with two other random people,
we allow you to do that.
And I guess the
big difference here
is we don't care so
much about ping times.
These are generally games where
a turn will last 24 hours,
and so ping times don't
really matter there.
The way the system
generally works
is that our servers keep some
information about your game.
So we know some data
that is associated
with that particular match.
We know the players
who are there
in the game or the
players that are waiting
to be invited into the game.
And we know who's turn it is.
We'll send that information on,
then, to the player who's turn
is supposed to be taken next.
That player's game client
will then take the turn,
update the game data,
and also determine
who's supposed to go next.
That information then gets
sent back to our servers.
We then pass that along
to the next player who
then will take their
turn, alter the game data,
determine who the
next player is,
send that back to us,
and so on and so forth.
And I should note this example
was kind of round robin,
but it doesn't have
to be that way.
Like if we were playing a
game like Risk or something
and our bunny were to get
eliminated from the game--
sorry-- our game
client could know that.
And we could determine,
oh, OK, the next player
to take their turn
is actually the bear.
And we would just pass that
information along to them.
So you can have turns going in
any arbitrary order you want.
Granted, most games tend to
just go around the table.
But again, it's
completely up to you.
In all of these
situations, both turn based
and real time, we provide
all the UI for you.
So if you don't
feel like spending
your time building out a let
me pick out with my friends
picker, and a waiting room, and
a let me see all of the games
that I have queued up and which
ones are waiting for me to take
my turn, I don't blame you.
That's really
boring stuff, and we
don't want you to have to do it.
On the other hand, if you have
a marketing department that
insists that you have a
consistent brand experience
throughout the blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah,
then we do let you grab all this
data directly from our service,
and you can go ahead and
you can create your own UI.
But again, that's up to you.
Our goal here is
that we want to make
sure you spend more
time on gameplay
and less time on UI work.
Gosh, I wonder if
we're going to be
able to eliminate that last bar.
Let's find out.
Sorry.
So I would be remiss if I didn't
mention a couple of drawbacks
here.
Because I do want to be
upfront about all of this.
As you know, all
this game data is
being generated by the
clients themselves.
And our server does nothing
more than pass that data along
from one player to the next.
As far as we're concerned,
that's an opaque blob of data.
We know nothing else about it.
And this has two implications.
One is that the user
with a hacked game client
could alter this in a way that
your game might not expect.
And of course, in this
kind of situation,
you just want to
code defensively.
Right?
You should always look at
any player generated data
with a little
amount of suspicion.
Right?
And make sure that if
something looks off to you,
you just reject it and don't
let it set your player on fire.
This also, by the way, means
that you don't have the ability
to perform any server side
logic or running batch calls
in the background via
Cron job or analytics
or anything like that.
Again, all the server is
really just on your client,
and our servers
just pass it around.
And I'll be honest.
This is generally
a concern you only
need to have once your
game gets more popular
or your company gets larger.
And when you do
get to this point,
it's fairly easy to make the
transition from keep your game
data on our clients to
keeping game data on, say,
servers that you're
running yourself
or your own cloud based
platform that you're using.
Something like App Engine, say.
Basically, you would keep the
entire system you have before.
The only difference is that
instead of your game data being
your actual game
data, the game data
would be a link to where
your real game data lives
on your server or on your App
Engine instance or whatever.
This, by the way, kind of gives
you the best of both worlds.
Right?
You can still keep
all of our UI if you
don't feel like
building out our UI.
You can still take advantage
of our notification system
to notify Android
and iOS devices.
And most importantly, your
players' incoming games
will still show up on the Play
Games app on Android devices
if they're looking at that.
But this also then means
that you get your data
on your servers, and you can
perform server side validation.
You can perform batch
processing in the background.
You can analyze all this data.
So this is kind of nice.
That being said,
I've talked to lots
of game developers,
even larger ones.
I don't think I've talked to
a single game developer that
wasn't strapped for server
engineering resources.
So if you're just
starting out and you're
trying to prove out you're
a minimum viable product
or you know what minimum
viable product means,
and you're at this
early iteration stage,
I would encourage you to stick
with the client only version
if you can.
And once you
actually have gotten
to the point where you say yes,
I think I have an actual fun
game, then go ahead
and transition
to this server solution.
But that's just
my recommendation.
So let's talk a little bit about
some implementation strategies.
Right now, we have
a Java library
available on Android
devices for those of you
who are writing games in Java.
And on the iOS side, we
have an Objective C library
for those of you who are
writing gains in Objective C.
But the truth is, not a lot
of people make games this way.
We did, or we tried it.
This is a game we built
called Nostalgic Racer,
and here's a quick
little demo of it.
And I'll be honest.
This was a terrible idea.
While this gameplay actually
works, if you watch,
you can see the cars' position
relative to each other
is correct.
Everything else looks off.
Right?
Like the color palette is off.
The car geometry is off.
Thanks to an off by one
error, the actual track
is off by a little bit.
And it turns out the
iPad accelerates faster
than the Android version.
So I usually won any
game that we played.
So this obviously
had a lot of issues,
and it also meant that
any type of change we made
had to be made twice.
Like once on the Java
code base and once
on the Objective C code base.
And so my guess is very
few of you are actually
building cross platform
games this way.
Or probably aren't any more
if you've tried it once.
And so for a lot
of you, that means
using some type of game
engine or middleware.
I know that one of the
more common ones out there
has been Unity.
I believe they're having
a developer day today.
But stay here.
This is going to be better.
So basically you write
your Unity project in C#,
or JavaScript if
you hate yourself.
And it basically--
[LAUGHTER] ah,
some JavaScript
engineers out here I see.
And it basically generates
a mono interpreter running
in C++.
And then there's
some work involved
in writing some scaffolding
to connect this generated code
to the libraries on the
two various platforms.
And there are various
ways to handle this part.
Some of you have
done it yourself.
There are some plug-ins out
there for you to do this.
And we have written
our own Unity plug-in
that is available
on our GitHub page.
It is open source.
It is freely available for
you to use, download, modify,
alter to your heart's content.
And we have had support for
achievements, cloud save
and leader boards
up until this point.
And this week we're going
to be adding support
for cross platform and real time
multiplayer on Android and iOS
devices.
So we're super happy about that.
And if any of you
are Unity engineers,
I think this is probably
the easiest way for you
to get a multiplayer game going.
So definitely check it out
if you're at all interested.
So here's an example of a
game we made using Unity.
We then took another
racing game and decided
to take all of the
excitement of car racing out
and replace it with math.
So here you're answering
questions to-- math questions
to make your car go faster.
And I know this
is super exciting,
but I'm guessing you
could do even better.
But the one thing I
do want you to notice
is that this does now look
like the same game running
on two different devices.
Right?
The aspect ratio is
a little different,
but we now actually have the
same game logic, the same game
behavior running on
both of these devices.
And we didn't have to make any
code changes to the C# project
to make this run cross platform.
There's no if application
dot platform dot whatever
equals iOS do this.
Right?
It's the same code base.
Which is pretty nice.
So implementing this is
pretty straightforward.
I'm not going to go
over it now because we
have a readme file
that you should read.
But basically the steps are
you would import this custom
package like you would
any other custom package.
We have a couple of dialogs
for you to fill out.
We have one question for
you to answer on Android,
and three questions for
you to answer on iOS.
And then we kind of do the
rest of the work for you.
The calls themselves,
they're just C# calls.
We went with the
strategy that we
want to make the common calls as
simple as possible and the more
obscure cases possible.
So you'll see here that
for instance, this call
here with four parameters
would bring up the entire hey,
let me invite some
folks to a game
and then return that
game to my listener.
We do implement the iSocial
interface where appropriate.
But in places where
we do more than what's
in the iSocial interface,
we have our own Play Games
platform that you would call.
And so I encourage
you to check it out.
But what about those of you
who don't use game engines
or have written your own?
Well, most likely, you've
written this in C++.
And then you've had to do this
somewhat annoying busy work
where you add in your thin layer
of abstraction so that you port
your C++ calls through JNI to
the Java library on Android,
and you do something else
on the iOS side of things.
And here's an extra bit of fun.
On Android for multiplayer, we
then make an extra bit of calls
back out to C++ for some
of the multiplayer stuff.
And so this is horrible.
And we thought, gee,
this is kind of a pain.
And so maybe if we're developing
a cross platform service,
we should have a cross
platform library.
And-- yeah, you
can clap for that.
We got-- [APPLAUSE] --alright.
C++ developers in the house.
That's a pointer right there.
[LAUGHTER] So anyway, sorry.
So we are releasing this week
a C++ library that you can use
for your own libraries
that you've written.
And I should point out this
isn't just a thin client that
supports REST calls.
I think there's a
bunch already out there
that do something similar.
We are adding in all of
the nice support features
that our Java and our Objective
C libraries already have.
And so this includes things
like OAuth2 management.
If your OAuth token
expires, we can go ahead
and get a new one
in the background
without your user ever knowing
that anything was wrong.
It means network retries.
So if your user has earned
an achievement on an airplane
and she has her phone
in airplane mode,
we will store that
call and keep it
until your user gets
off the airplane,
turns off airplane
mode, and then we
will retry that
call to make sure
that she gets that
achievement she's earned.
It doesn't get dropped,
which is really nice.
We have some intelligent
local caching.
If you submit a score
to a leaderboard that's
not as good as one you
submitted five minutes ago,
we won't make that
call out to the server.
That will save your user
a little bit of data
and also a little bit of battery
life, which is always nice.
We have UI widgets
so that, again, you
don't have to spend
your time building out
a let's show all of the
achievements with icons
depending on whether or not the
user has unlocked them or not.
Again, you can leave
that UI work to us.
And we have a much better
threading model on Android.
So all of our methods are
non-blocking asynchronous calls
that can be called
on any thread.
If you're an Android engineer,
this is very exciting.
If you're not, write that down
and go back to your office
and tell your Android
engineer and he or she
will give you a big hug.
I should point out
this is version 1.0.
So the library itself
is production ready,
although in terms of
features right now,
we have support for sign-in,
leaderboards, and achievements.
That's what we currently have.
I am not supposed to
commit to future features.
But clearly our goal here is
to have all features available
on all devices.
So hopefully you can kind of
see where we're going with this.
And all of this means that
you can spend less time
on code scaffolding work and
more time on your game play.
We did it.
We got rid of that last bar.
That's so great.
So let's review.
Here are the big things
that we talked about today.
Real-time multiplayer
on iOS and Android,
turn-based asynchronous
multiplayer that you can play
between iOS and Android devices,
a full featured Unity plug-in,
and a C++ library that you can
start hacking with I think,
like, today.
Yeah.
And so I think with that, all
the tools and all the power
are sort of in your hands now.
We want to play games in
the Kerpelman household,
and there are millions of
households and schoolyards
and conferences
just like this one,
all full of people
looking to do one thing.
And that's play together.
You know, Macs and PCs have
played together for years.
And even then while
most of the burden
has been on the
developer to add this,
I think it's been a huge benefit
to both of those platforms
as well as to players
and those developers.
Right?
And we have an even
bigger opportunity here.
If all of the reports
are right, the number
of smart phones in the world is
going to pass the number of PCs
out there in the world.
And so many of these
people are gamers.
Right?
So many.
And so we have this opportunity
to bring the world together
in gaming experiences
that have never
been seen before in the
history of civilization.
Like, ever.
And I think that's
pretty exciting.
Hopefully you do too.
So thank you very much.
Go ahead and follow
me on G+ or Twitter.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]